if I put my hand in front of the beam a
Large Hadron Collider what would happen
to my hand
dodo dodo dodo ice gosh that's a good
question I don't know is the answer but
would be very bad for you I don't know
the total amount of energy that'll be
distributed in our Donnell the energy
density another good idea wouldn't
recommend it
if I was to put my hand in the beam of
the Large Hadron Collider what would
happen to my hand certainly wouldn't
advise doing that and the safety that we
have implemented here is such that
there's zero possibility you could ever
do that
so let's make it a theoretical
experiment that you actually did that
the beam itself is focused down very
tightly as less than a millimeter across
extremely intense the actual energy
carried by the beam is like an aircraft
carrier in motion and it's a massive
amount of energy there so you really
wouldn't want to put your hand in there
it'd make a hole straight through it I
put my hand in front of the beam in the
Large Hadron Collider right now nothing
there's no beat when there's beam it
would hurt okay there's a there's a
train going through there at full speed
basically that's the amount of energy
that there is so yeah you wouldn't you
it would hurt your hand quite a bit but
it's not just that tiny part of being
the beam or the proton beam is
accompanied by what's called a halo of
electrons and some muons as well they
extend out quite far some of which can
be you know meters away so there's an
intense beam of particles coming down
that accompanies this extremely intense
part so your whole body would be
irradiated you'd die pretty quickly I
think that the the more it's gonna burn
right through you basically it's gonna
burn through that soft tissue we at we
can argue you can only see it there's
some examples where they put metal in
front of various beams and you can see
the holes that it can make in it so I'm
sorry I would hurt it would hurt a lot I
have to say I haven't really thought
about this very much I don't think it
would explode your hand I can't see any
mechanism for that to happen it'd be
more like a laser so a very intense beam
that would just go straight through your
hand and destroy anything in its path
you